so let's talk about the culture of music
so we have some agreements and we have
some disagreements on the culture of
music famously
uh so when it comes to the culture of of
music
that is consumed in the black community
obviously rap is at the top of the list
there's obviously a huge gap between the
high forms of art that have been created
by members of the black community and
the rap culture of today
i mean it's a pretty broad range between
nat king cole and louis armstrong and
duke ellington
and say cardi b who's now i guess
interviewing the former vice president
of the united states
um what what do you make of rap culture
because you have sort of a split opinion
on unwrapped culture
a little bit like on the one hand uh you
seem to recognize some of the downsides
of the messages being pervaded on the
other hand
you've suggested that there are some
sort of differential messages in there
that might be useful
right so i mean there are definitely a
minority of rappers who are rapping
about things that are actually important
um and and i i grew up listening to
jay-z i don't like jay-z anymore because
of his politics and i think he's being
used and he's become a puppet but
growing up listening to his music
actually uh did something differently
did something different for me when i
was uh you know a hopeless
uh impoverished person listening to his
music and he talked about how he made
his way out he wasn't talking about
you know killing a bunch of people he
was talking about business you know and
his black album he really talks about
how he would not allow industry to use
him how he understood what his worth was
these things were actually important
lessons
um about uh business and and and it came
in
a lyrical form and it was good right i
would say kanye west he's never really
written about like go out grab a gat and
just kill people
but unfortunately today that's the
majority of what what rap has become
right and and so and i completely agree
with your assessment about cardi b
um it is one of the biggest insults if
black americans are not insulted
by the fact that joe biden who has been
hiding in his basement um
you know for the entire year made an
appearance to came up because he was
going to do an interview with cardi b
do we do we have nothing better to offer
i mean this would be akin to donald
trump saying
i'm going to give no interviews but he
came up and he decided to give an
interview
to justin bieber right i mean i wish i
actually
justin bieber i'm sorry i know you're a
christian man i only want to put you in
the same boat as cardi b
um but it would be absurd right white
america would go what what is this why
why are you being interviewed by justin
bieber and it's because you're pandering
right you're pandering you look at cardi
b's instagram you see she has millions
of followers and you think okay
this is an illiterate person and if i if
i appeal to this illiterate person and
she does
oh like she literally did uh uh in the
middle of this interview
and they think she's cool she's hip just
by sitting here and and taking this
interview black people vote for me it's
basically saying
black people you are stupid you are dumb
and you're so foolish i mean
do you think what if she just said in
the middle of the interview joe biden
can you name
one cardi b album you know jordan do me
a favor just one cardi b
lyric he couldn't do it of course he's
not because he's being handled and
they're saying black people like this
person this is what they're into
and and so here you go talk to her same
thing with hillary clinton when she went
in the breakfast club
and she said she had hot sauce in her
bag right she didn't know what beyonce's
came from
wonderful handler said say this right
probably got the questions ahead of time
say this
say you keep hot sauce in your bag right
now beyonce's uh song is trending and
it's hot sauce in my bag swag
and she looked like a fish out of water
and said it it is demeaning it is
pandering it is ridiculous
okay and she asked pointedly ridiculous
questions i want lower taxes but i want
universal health care for all she had no
idea what she was doing
and yet both bernie sanders and joe
biden made the time to sit with her
because they believe black people are
stupid
and black people that thought yay that's
a win no it's not a win it shows you
that they still believe
that you are so stupid that they
couldn't find many of the
amazing intellectual black people that
we have in the world to sit down with
and ask them
tough questions an interview with
condoleezza rice right an interview with
larry elder
uh you know if even if you want somebody
that's that is a democrat that's fine
there are way more intellectual black
democrats you could have sat down with
it you
you chose an illiterate rapper because
that's what she is she's illiterate
well i mean i would have paid money to
hear joe biden's rendition
of what else as a popular rap artist
myself
whose remix slaps significantly harder
than the original
i i can honestly say that joe biden's
rendition i would have paid good money
so i need to ask you about the kanye
issue so uh famously he had a little bit
of a teddy ted on on twitter yeah when i
when kanye came out and he was uh
supporting president trump and i said
live by the kanye die by the kanye which
is
mainly saying you know kanye takes a lot
of positions on a lot of different
issues
uh and you got a little bit upset about
that it seemed uh on twitter so
what do you think is the proper
relationship between celebrity and
politics because
i am a strict down the line i think that
celebrities have no place in politics
unless they actually know what they are
talking about on any sort of deep level
you know i understand the impact of
celebrity i understand but but i object
to it
right but you have i think a more
nuanced version of that so what's your
view on celebrity and politics yeah you
know with kanye i think what i was upset
with was that so many people were just
dismissing him and calling him crazy
and it's it's just not fair i mean i
think i like kanye kane's in front
connie's a friend
um and kanye is a person that is a
billionaire and i don't i would not take
someone
you know to be like he's richer than
both you and i sitting here combined
right
i'm assuming i don't know maybe you're a
billionaire um and and people keep
taking him lightly and he it's been his
entire life
kanye was not coming out telling people
how to vote he never said vote for this
person he never said do this he never
said listen to me follow me he simply
said i support the president
and i'm tired of people bullying me
telling me that i can't wear a maga hat
and that was
such an important message especially for
black americans
and maybe um maybe i was emotional in my
response because it is
it is so hard you try being a black
conservative a miss black lives matter
right
and and go out and say i support the
president and you will see how you how
you get treated right
uh you it's easy you get called racist
with us it's it there is a
it's ferocious they want you gone i mean
they will accuse you of anything they
want you gone
you get death threats you get all these
horrible things and here's a guy that's
just saying
i'm no longer going to lie about who i
support not if you don't support him
you're a racist i mean we know his wife
is not a trump supporter despite the
fact that she works with them and i
thought this is this is productive it's
a good thing for someone to say
i'm comfortable saying that i'm black
and i'm a conservative in the cultural
realm especially because we know
most black americans have their eyes
fixed culturally that it just sent a
huge signal that it's okay
to break away from the from the hive
mentality um now if kanye was out there
saying i'd like to inform policy
uh because i'm kanye west i'd like to go
in i will now be conducting the
interviews
i want to sit down with canada to make
sure that what they're doing is great i
would have said
i have a problem with that right because
that's ridiculous assume that
that because you're uh you know a
cultural figure you somehow are now
smart enough to be asking political
questions just pointedly ridiculous
so that was the nuance he wasn't doing
anything um that i found to be harmful
he just was saying i support the
president so i actually agree that i
think that it's actually a very
important thing that
that kanye west put on a maga hat and
basically said you know what it's fine
i'm allowed to wear a maga hat yeah and
someone who's been called a jewish nazi
for
being a republican right i certainly
understand the uh the
perspective of being inside a minority
group where it is considered verboten
uh to to be on a different side of the
political aisle so
i'm very glad that happened i mean
speaking of which you know you talk
about sort of policy influences one of
one of the areas in which
kanye and kim actually did have a policy
influences on criminal justice reform i
know that you're an advocate
also i believe of criminal justice
reform so i was uh i had some difficulty
with the criminal justice reform bill
that the trump administration
pushed mainly because i was not of the
opinion the criminal justice system is
inherently racist i think there's a case
to be made that we should
cut back on the drug war because i think
that and there are a lot of people in
jail for
for ridiculous silly crimes right or
crimes that at least they were in jail
for too long for
um but uh overall i'm not of the opinion
that this is that people are being
incarcerated for no reason or that grass
incarceration is a serious problem so
where are you on on criminal justice
reform
do you think that that is a in an
effective version of outreach to black
americans
i think you can i i don't think there's
a dichotomy here i think you can
believe in criminal justice reform
without you know subscribing to the idea
that black people are being put into
jail for no reason i don't i don't
believe
i believe both i do not believe that
black americans are being put into
prison for no reason
but i do believe that some of the
harsher sentencing that happened you
know when bill clinton became president
three strikes you're out even if it's
three small things three strikes you're
out were wrong
and a lot of people were still serving
for sentences because of that um so i
think
you know uh it it's good to take a look
at the criminal system i don't think
it's great and i'm someone who grew up
with uncles
um that were in and out of prison um i i
know for a fact when you get a kid when
they're young and they're in the system
if you can help them get out like when
they leave they get 50
in a bus ticket right uh what do you
expect someone who's been in prison for
a year you have the fifty dollars in a
bus ticket to do
in their life right they usually go back
to crime because they have nothing
and so their way of trying to get ahead
is to steal to rob do these things
what i loved about what they were doing
was creating these transition to these
transition programs which were so
desperately needed because
you don't want somebody who's desperate
dropped back into your community
you want somebody who goes okay we're
gonna we're gonna help you find a job
we're gonna help you get on your two
feet and that that is what i loved and
support about the programming
i do not at all believe uh that black
americans are being targeted by the
criminal justice system at all i'm
actually staunchly against that
you know we we commit more crimes did
you know that every like on this video
creates one additional
leftist tier gleaming in the sunshine
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity hit the like button